.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Eva und Marc
freuen sich auf ihr Kind.
Doch diese Schwangerschaft
ist nicht unbeschwert.
Vor einem Jahr ist die Tochter des
Paares kurz vor der Geburt gestorben.
Es mag blöd klingen,
aber ich hoffte bis zuletzt,
dass sich die Ärzte irren
und sie trotzdem lebt.
Ängste begleiten das Paar
durch die Schwangerschaft.
Das klingt gut.
- Zufrieden? Der Wert ist perfekt.
Na, was meinst du?
Mich wieder auf mich selbst
konzentrieren und mich spüren.
Die Pferde
schenken einem ein Körpergefühl
und helfen einem dabei,
auf sein Bauchgefühl zu hören.
Ein Zurück gibt es nicht mehr.
(Schmerzerfüllt) Ah, verdammt!
* Sie schluchzt. *
Sind die Rosafarbenen etwas dünner?
- (Verkäuferin) Ja, anscheinend.
Okay.
Habe ich
eine gute Auswahl getroffen?
(Ohne Enthusiasmus) Ja, ja.
- (Lachend) Typisch Mann.
Das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
* Eva lacht. *
Der Rote passt auch dazu.
- (Beide) Ja.
Eine Familie gründen,
das hat sich das Paar aus dem Zürcher
Oberland schon immer gewünscht.
In drei Monaten soll
ihr zweites Kind zur Welt kommen.
Wenn es nicht irgendwo
im Nirgendwo landet. Okay?
Ich hatte einfach
den Eindruck, dass ...
... Eva für mich die Richtige ist,
um eine Familie zu gründen.
Wir waren uns von Anfang an sicher,
dass wir Kinder wollen.- Mhm.
Für uns ist das ...
Für uns gehört das dazu.
Es gehört zum Leben.
- Ja.
Heute ist ein besonderer Tag.
Der erste Geburtstag
ihrer Tochter Mayrie.
Mayrie ist ein Sternenkind.
Sie starb kurz vor der Geburt völlig
unerwartet im Bauch der Mutter.
Es ist schon ein harter ...
... aber eigentlich
auch ein schöner Tag,
da es der Tag ist,
an dem wir Eltern wurden.
Für mich ist es schon auch wichtig,
daran zu denken,
was vor einem Jahr passierte.
Hier könnte es klappen.
- Ich denke schon.
Aber du musst auf die Wiese,
sonst hängen sie im Baum.
Ja, ja, das klappt schon.
Damit wir eine Filmaufnahme ...
... von diesem Moment machen können.
* Die Drohne piepst. *
Du musst noch weiter
raus in die Wiese.
Ja, ich weiss.
* Vogelzwitschern *
"Meine geliebte Tochter Mayrie,
heute ist dein erster Geburtstag
im Himmel."
"Eigentlich sollten wir jetzt alle
zusammen an einem Tisch sitzen
und deinen ersten Kuchen essen."
* Schniefen, tiefer Atemzug *
"Anstatt dessen stehen wir nun hier
mit einer Handvoll Luftballons
und deinem kleinen Bruder im Bauch."
"Dazu eine ganze Gästeliste
deiner kleinen Sternenfreunde,
die mit dir mitfeiern."
"Du fehlst uns so sehr,
kleine Prinzessin."
"Wir versuchen heute einen
wunderschönen Tag zu verbringen,
dich immer ganz nah dabei."
"Wir feiern deinen Tag,
denn es ist dein Geburtstag."
"Happy birthday in heaven, Mayrie.
Wir lieben dich, deine Eltern."
Eins ...
... zwei ...
... drei.
Ah!
Es geht nicht.
* Surren und Piepsen der Drohne *
(Freudig) Jawohl.
- Doch, es geht.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Meine Grossmutter mütterlicherseits
ist auch
in diesem Waldfriedhof begraben.
Nicht in unmittelbarer Nähe von
Mayrie, aber im selben Waldstück.
Es war einfach ein schöner Gedanke,
dass ...
... ihre Asche
wieder für neues Wachstum sorgt.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Es ist krass,
dass bereits ein Jahr verging.
Erst eins?
Für mich sind es schon ... Du hast
ein anderes Zeitgefühl als ich.
Als wir erfuhren,
dass das Herz nicht mehr schlug ...
... wünschte ich mir
einen Kaiserschnitt.
Meine erste Reaktion war: "Holt das
tote Kind aus meinem Bauch raus."
Ähm ...
Sie berieten uns sehr gut
und sagten,
dass eine normale Geburt
für meinen Körper,
aber auch für meine Psyche
besser sei.
Die Geburt war anstrengend.
Ich war ziemlich
am Ende meiner Kräfte.
Marc unterstützte mich sehr gut.
Es ist sicher nicht
mit einer normalen Geburt
eines lebenden Kindes
zu vergleichen,
aber es war auf jeden Fall schön,
dass wir sie auf ganz
natürlichem Weg gebären konnten.
Ja, man musste sie nicht rausholen.
- Ja.
Mein erster Gedanke war eigentlich:
"Nun hat es Eva
fürs Erste überstanden."
Und ...
Ja ...
Mein zweiter Gedanke war:
"Das Kind schreit nicht."
Es mag blöd klingen,
aber ich hoffte bis zuletzt,
dass sich die Ärzte irren
und sie trotzdem lebt.
Aber das war ...
... Wunschdenken.
Ich denke sehr oft an die langen
Zehen, die sie hatte.- Mhm.
Das war etwas Besonderes
und fiel mir als Erstes auf.
Und ...
- Sie hatte meine Nase.
Hatte sie deine Nase?
- Ja.
Wir gehen gleich direkt zur Burg.
Wir ziehen uns nicht um.
Wir sehen ja gut aus.
* Marc lacht. *
Ja.
Dass Mayries Herz
zu schlagen aufhörte,
konnten wir nicht beeinflussen.
Wir hätten zig Untersuchungen
machen lassen können ...
... aber man hätte es ...
- ... wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen.
Es passierte einfach.
Ich denke, es ist ...
... wenn man das erkennt ...
... wird einem vor Augen geführt,
dass es
keineswegs selbstverständlich ist,
dass wir leben und gesund sind.
Die traurigen Erfahrungen
haben das Paar geprägt.
Deshalb lässt sich Eva
in der Schwangerschaft
medizinisch engmaschig begleiten.
Ich stehe jetzt auf dem Parkplatz
des Spitals Wetzikon und ...
Ich bin zurzeit etwas beunruhigt,
weil ich grosse Angst habe,
dass etwas nicht in Ordnung ist.
Ich freue mich aber auch,
den Kleinen wiederzusehen.
Baby-TV ist immer cool.
Ähm, ja, jetzt schauen wir mal,
was die Ärzte meinen.
* Angespannte Klänge *
Die 23-Jährige hat nicht nur
ein Kind tot zur Welt gebracht,
sondern bereits sechs Fehlgeburten
in der Frühschwangerschaft erlitten.
Die Angst
vor einem weiteren Kindsverlust
begleitet Eva
durch die Schwangerschaft.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Eigentlich gut,
aber ich bin sehr müde.
Körperlich geht es mir gut,
aber die psychische Anspannung
wird grösser.
Sie wird
von Woche zu Woche extremer.
Aber ich war ja darauf vorbereitet,
dass das so sein wird, daher ...
Benötigen Sie diesbezüglich Hilfe?
Nein, ich kann mich
relativ gut selbst auffangen.
Super, dann schauen wir es uns an.
(Lachend) Ja, mal sehen,
was der kleine Mann meint.
Haben Sie ein Ziehen im Bauch?
Ja, etwa ...
... viermal pro Tag
habe ich Übungswehen.
Gestern zog es wegen des langen
Stehens ziemlich stark nach unten.
Das Köpfchen liegt unten?
Ja, und hier sieht man
das Herz pochen.
Es bewegt sich etwas von uns weg.
Das ist besser.
* Herztöne *
Ja, wunderbar.
Das klingt gut.
- Zufrieden? Der Wert ist perfekt.
Er bewegt sich wirklich gut.
Das zeigt er uns sehr schön.
Oh, schauen Sie,
wenigstens eine solche Nase.
(Begeistert) Oh, ja.
Evas Gebärmutterform erschwert es
den befruchteten Eizellen,
sich einzunisten.
Eine Operation war geplant.
Doch es kam anders.
Diese Schwangerschaft
kam dazwischen und hat gehalten.
Es sind noch 13 Wochen
bis zum Geburtstermin.
Medizinisch ist alles in Ordnung.
Mentale Unterstützung
bietet Alessia an.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Sie ist eine Doula -
eine ausgebildete Schwanger-
schafts- und Geburtsbegleiterin.
Die beiden Frauen
verbindet eine ähnliche Geschichte.
Ich komme einfach rein, okay?
- Ja.
Möchtest du etwas trinken?
- Ja, gern.
Alessias Unterstützung
kann das Paar gut gebrauchen.
Das sind besondere Tücher.
Sie sind eigentlich ziemlich steif,
aber sie geben nach,
wenn man sie sich umbindet.
Wenn eine Wehe kommt,
kann man etwas daran ziehen.
Gleichzeitig könnte man ...
Darf ich dich anfassen?
Ja.- Gleichzeitig könnte man
hier hinten etwas dagegendrücken.
Willst du auch mal, Marc?
Du kannst ein bisschen ziehen.
- Aha, anheben?
Ja. Dann schaust du,
ob es für sie ...
Ist das okay?
Tut das so gut?
- (Lachend) Es tut total gut.
Doula bedeutet übersetzt
Dienerin der Frau.
Ich finde diesen Ausdruck ...
... schrecklich.
Er ist nicht so angebracht.
Ich bin keine Dienerin.
Ich bezeichne mich lieber
als Freundin auf Zeit,
da es etwas sehr Intimes ist und ...
Meistens entsteht
eine schöne Freundschaft,
die irgendwann wieder endet
bzw. nicht mehr so intensiv ist.
Eine Doula ist v.a. jemand, der ...
... Frauen während
der Schwangerschaft, der Geburt
und wenn gewünscht
im Wochenbett begleitet.
Es ist nichts Medizinisches.
Es ist nur eine Begleitung
des Paars oder der Frau -
v.a. in mentaler Hinsicht.
Wenn während der Geburt irgendetwas
passiert, wünsche ich mir,
dass ich nicht
unter Vollnarkose gesetzt werde,
sondern bei vollem Bewusstsein bin
und dass Marc und du
dabei sein dürft.
Ja.
Sie sorgt mit Worten dafür, dass ich
wieder Boden unter den Füssen habe.
Sie sagt:
"Beruhig dich, es ist alles okay."
"Das muss nichts bedeuten."
Ab und zu fragt sie mich
ein paar Dinge und beruhigt mich,
wenn ich unsicher bin.
Ich finde das grossartig.
Wenn Eva das Ganze so sehr hilft ...
... bin ich auch dafür,
dass wir das machen.
Ja, ich möchte, dass du während
der Geburt nicht ganz allein bist.
Tja ...
- Vielleicht könnte es dir helfen.
Ob es wirklich hilft,
werden wir sehen.
Aber ich möchte, dass du das
nicht ganz allein durchstehen musst.
Vielleicht wird schon die eine
oder andere Emotion hochkommen.
Mal sehen.
Man weiss es nicht genau.
- Genau.
Und ... Was wollte ich noch sagen?
Zum Thema Essen nach der Geburt ...
- Ja, was isst du gern?
Ähm, Sushi.
Ich spiele auch noch eat.ch.
Dann riecht alles nach Fisch.
- Na und?
Magst du kein Sushi?
- Es muss nicht viel sein.
Das finde ich gut.
- Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Es soll nur
eine kleine Belohnung sein.
Eine Geburt ist wie ein Marathon.
Ja, das stimmt.
Alessia hat auch ein Sternenkind.
Ihr drittes Kind
ist während der Geburt gestorben -
völlig unerwartet, nach einer
problemlosen Schwangerschaft.
Eva und Marc liegen mir
sehr am Herzen, weil sie auch ...
... ein Sternenkind haben.
Ich weiss, mit welchen Ängsten
man konfrontiert wird.
Das gemeinsame Schicksal
schweisst zusammen
und hilft,
mit der Situation umzugehen.
Marc nennt ihn immer Dave.
Das ist sein Spitzname.
(Liebevoll) Als würdest du
etwas zu essen kriegen.
Bei der Arbeit mit den Pferden
findet Eva Ruhe und schöpft Kraft.
Bei Sorgen und Angst in der
Schwangerschaft ist das sehr schön,
weil ich dadurch
alles vergessen kann.
Als ich als Ferienvertretung
tätig war,
holte ich mir abends,
nachdem wir die Pferde
auf die Weide gelassen hatten,
oft einen Stuhl, setzte mich hin
und schaute den Pferden
auf der Weide zu.
So konnte ich runterfahren,
mich auf mich selbst konzentrieren
und mich wieder spüren.
Die Pferde
schenken einem ein Körpergefühl
und helfen einem dabei,
auf sein Bauchgefühl zu hören.
* Stöhnen *
Diesen Huf
kannst du mir nochmals geben.
* Schnalzen *
Komm mit.
Wegen der Beckenbodenmuskulatur
reite ich nicht.
Wenn diese etwas zu ausgeprägt ist,
wird es bei der Geburt schwieriger.
Man benötigt zwar eine gewisse
Kontrolle über die Muskulatur,
aber zu viel Muskulatur
ist auch schwierig.
Und Po.
Gut.
Und voran.
* Schnalzen *
Nein, nein, alles okay.
Bei der Trauerverarbeitung
half mir der Umgang mit den Pferden
am meisten:
Zeit mit ihnen zu verbringen,
mich auf der Weide aufzuhalten,
das Futter vorzubereiten
und im Stall zu sein.
* Emotionale Klänge *
Marc und ich sind zurzeit unterwegs.
Er holt beim Bäcker gerade Brötchen.
Danach haben wir
unser Schwangerschaftsshooting -
mit wunderschöner Morgensonne
am Sihlsee.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Man ist natürlich
immer wieder mit dieser ...
Es ist nicht direkt Angst,
aber man fragt sich immer wieder:
"Ist alles in Ordnung?"
"Wird alles gut?"
Das begleitet einen natürlich.
Insbesondere wenn der Kleine
mal einen ruhigeren Tag hat,
weil er schläft ...
... sage ich mir, dass alles
noch im normalen Rahmen ist.
Nach 3, 3 1/2 Std.
entschliesse ich mich jedoch,
mit dem Doppler
die Herztöne zu kontrollieren,
um sicher zu sein,
dass wirklich alles okay ist.
Dann ist nicht
nur mein Unterbewusstsein,
das mir sagt,
dass alles in Ordnung ist,
sondern auch mein Bewusstsein
beruhigt
und ich weiss, dass alles okay ist.
Die Herztöne abhören, das beruhigt.
Es ist etwas zu tief.
* Rauschen *
Momentan hat er keine Lust.
* Leise Herztöne *
So.
* Rauschen *
Und schon ist er wieder weg.
Ich kontrolliere,
ob die Herzfrequenz hoch genug ist.
Insbesondere wenn er etwas ruhiger
ist und sich länger nicht bewegt,
möchte ich sichergehen,
dass alles okay ist.
Und, ähm ...
Es ist schön,
ab und zu die Herztöne zu hören.
Dann weiss ich, dass er da ist.
* Rauschen *
Beide haben ihre eigenen Strategien,
mit ihren Ängsten umzugehen.
Im virtuellen Raum
hebt der 32-jährige Marc ab.
Jetzt bin ich
über der Sierra Nevada unterwegs.
Das ist ...
Das ist
eine militärische Simulation.
In der Sierra Nevada
befindet sich z.B. ein
amerikanisches Trainingsgelände ...
... wo für Kampfeinsätze
trainiert wird.
Es nimmt einem
etwas die Unsicherheit
in Bezug auf die Geburt
und die Nervosität natürlich auch.
Insbesondere mit der VR-Brille,
die ich gerade trage ...
... taucht man
in eine völlig andere Welt ein.
Dieses Flugzeugcockpit ist natürlich
etwas anderes als der Alltag.
Meine Liebe zu Marc fühlt sich an,
als würde ich nach Hause kommen.
Er ist eine Konstante
und ich fühle mich wohl bei ihm.
Egal wo ich bin - wenn er dabei ist,
fühle ich mich zu Hause.
Das zeigte mir,
dass er derjenige ist,
mit dem ich mein restliches Leben
verbringen will.
Ich denke immer noch darüber nach,
wie ich das beantworten soll.
Es ist sehr schwierig für mich.
Was uns
stark zusammengeschweisst hat,
war die Sache mit Mayrie.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Andere Paare,
mit denen v.a. du in Kontakt stehst,
packten das ...
... nicht so gut wie wir.
Ihr Schicksal hat Eva
zu einer neuen Berufung geführt.
Mit ihrer Erfahrung will sie
in Zukunft andere unterstützen.
Ich mache zurzeit eine Ausbildung
als Trauerbegleiterin,
die auf Sterneneltern
spezialisiert ist.
Nächstes Jahr, wenn mein
Mutterschaftsurlaub vorbei ist,
möchte ich in unserem Dorf einen
Sternenelterntreff ins Leben rufen.
Alle Eltern sprechen ja
gern über ihre Kinder.
Wenn das Kind nicht da ist, kann man
nicht so viele Geschichten erzählen.
Man kann nicht erzählen, dass sein
Kind etwas Bestimmtes geschafft hat,
dass es sich nun drehen kann
oder zum ersten Mal gebrabbelt hat.
Über all das
können wir nicht sprechen.
Bei uns sind es immer
die gleichen Geschichten.
Aber teils kommen
auch neue Dinge hinzu.
Manchmal erhalten wir
ein kleines Zeichen,
z.B. in Form eines Marienkäferchens
oder eines flackernden Lichts.
Andere Eltern
verstehen nicht so gut,
dass uns das in diesem Moment
enorm viel bedeutet.
Vielleicht ist es
auch etwas schwachsinnig, wer weiss.
Es ist Ansichtssache,
ob man an ein Leben nach dem Tod
glaubt oder nicht.
Aber für die Eltern,
die daran glauben
und diese Zeichen wahrnehmen,
ist es extrem schön,
solche Erlebnisse teilen zu können.
Mayrie hat ihren festen Platz
im Leben des Paares.
Immer wieder baut Eva
Rituale in ihren Alltag ein.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Sie ist ein Teil unseres Lebens,
und das wird sie immer bleiben.
Ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Was zurzeit am meisten schmerzt,
ist die Tatsache,
dass sie nicht da ist.
Dass sie nicht
bei uns gross werden darf,
dass sie fehlt.
Dass sie diese Welt
nicht kennenlernen darf,
dass wir sie ihr
nicht zeigen dürfen.
Auch in Alessias Leben
ist das verstorbene Kind -
ihr Sohn Niven - präsent.
Ich war immer der Meinung,
dass es pures Leben bedeutet,
wenn ich ein Kind zur Welt bringe
und dass es mehr Leben
in unsere Familie bringt.
Für mich war das
die pure Lebensfreude.
Doch dann war das Kind einfach tot,
ein kalter Mensch.
Das war eine sehr grosse Heraus-
forderung für die ganze Familie,
das ganze Umfeld.
Noch viel schlimmer
war das Nachhausekommen,
zur Haustür hereinzukommen
und zu wissen,
dass alles bereit wäre.
Wir hatten ein Zimmer vorbereitet
und es stand alles bereit.
Das war eine extrem
einschneidende Erfahrung.
Zeit mit dem verstorbenen Kind
zu verbringen,
heisst für mich in erster Linie,
das Kind kennenzulernen,
es zu berühren.
Viele Leute haben
im ersten Moment Berührungsängste,
weil viele noch nie
einen toten Menschen gesehen haben
oder sich nicht vorstellen können,
dass man sein totes Kind berühren,
in die Arme nehmen
und mehrere Stunden
mit ihm verbringen kann.
Es gibt auch Eltern,
die das gar nicht können.
Bei mir war das so.
Ich sah meinen Sohn nie
und berührte ihn nie,
weil ich komplett überfordert war
und niemand da war,
der mich an die Hand nahm
und mich zu meinem Sohn führte.
Daher ist mir das extrem wichtig.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl,
dass mir etwas fehlt,
aber es wäre wohl anders,
wenn ich das erlebt hätte.
Immer mehr Sterneneltern nehmen
professionelle Hilfe in Anspruch.
Viele Betroffene bilden sich weiter,
teilen ihre eigenen Erfahrungen
und leisten Unterstützung.
Im Rahmen des Vereins Himmelskind
leistet Alessia
Akutbegleitung bei Kindsverlust.
Sie und ihr Team
sind rund um die Uhr abrufbar.
Für mich gehören das Leben
und der Tod zusammen.
Daher ist es schön,
dass das harmonisieren kann.
Anfangs befürchtete ich,
dass es nicht zusammenpasst,
aber jetzt finde ich, dass das Leben
und der Tod zusammengehören.
Ich finde es schön,
dass ich mit beidem arbeiten kann.
Ich darf dabei sein,
wenn der erste Atemzug getan wird,
und ich war auch schon dabei,
als der letzte getan wurde.
Das ist schön.
Wenn ich eine Geburt begleite,
ist es mir wichtig,
dass ich das Paar
schon ein bisschen kenne,
damit ich es
in ihren Wünschen unterstützen kann.
Eva ist jetzt
in der 36. Schwangerschaftswoche.
Gibt es Bewegungen? Geht es ihm gut?
- Sehr gut.
Nicht erschrecken,
ich fasse Ihren Bauch an.
Ich mache eine Ausbildung als
Trauerbegleiterin bei Kindsverlust.
Sehr gut. Konnten Sie das
direkt umsetzen?- Ja.
Wow, das ist toll.
Das werden Sie gewiss gut machen.
Die ärztliche Betreuung ist intensiv.
Das Kindlein soll kurz
vor dem eigentlichen Geburtstermin
auf die Welt kommen.
Wir leiten die Geburt so früh ein,
weil das Herz meiner Tochter
das letzte Mal bei 38+4, also in
der 39. Woche, zu schlagen aufhörte.
Daher wollten wir nun
auf Nummer sicher gehen.
Wir wollten sicherstellen, dass
die Plazenta nicht verbraucht ist,
dass die Durchblutung gewährleistet
ist, damit nichts schiefgeht.
Akupunktur soll Eva
auf die Geburt vorbereiten.
Heute soll es losgehen.
Anspannung und Vorfreude steigen.
Fass mal meinen Bauch an.
Er ist steinhart.
Aber das liegt doch nicht an ihm.
Nein, das sind Senkwehen.
- Ah.
Hier drin ist noch mehr:
Gummibärchen, Balisto ...
Ich glaube, wir haben alles.
Wie lange sind wir dort?
Das reicht ja für mehrere Wochen.
So haben wir genug dabei, falls wir
zwischendurch Hunger kriegen.
Mhm.
Die werdenden Eltern machen sich
auf den Weg ins Spital Wetzikon.
(Frau) Guten Tag, Frau Düby.
- Guten Tag.
Kommen Sie nur rein.
- Freut mich.
Hallo.
Ich habe ein ganz gutes Bauchgefühl.
Ich glaube, es kommt alles,
wie es kommen muss.
Und, äh ...
Ich hoffe, dass wir das Ganze nach
diesem Wochenende überstanden haben
und nicht mehr länger warten müssen.
Mal sehen,
wie lange es wirklich dauert.
Wehenfördernde Medikamente
unterstützen
das Einsetzen der Geburtswehen -
doch Geduld ist gefragt.
* Eva stöhnt. *
Mensch.
Je mehr er sich bewegt,
desto stärker werden die Wehen.
Das ist doch gut,
dann geht es voran.
(Seufzend) Ja.
- Hm?
Das stimmt.
Melde dich,
wenn ich dir etwas bringen soll.
Alles okay.
Das Bistro ist bis 18 Uhr geöffnet.
Bereits 24 Std. sind vergangen.
Die Wehen sind immer noch schwach.
Was?
Willst du meinen Rohschinken?
Das grösste Problem ist zurzeit,
dass er nicht richtig
ins Becken rutscht.
Ähm ...
Dadurch öffnet sich
der Muttermund nicht richtig.
Nun ist die Frage:
Will ich die Wehen verstärken
und einen Wehensturm riskieren?
Ich habe ja bereits Wehen.
Durch die Tabletten lassen sie sich
jedoch relativ gut dosieren.
Es ist eine enorm lange Warterei.
Man denkt immer wieder:
"Ah, jetzt geht es gleich los."
Aber dann
flauen die Wehen wieder ab
und man wartet wieder.
Es ist ein langes Warten.
Kommen sie jetzt alle 5 Min.?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ungefähr.
Aber ich glaube schon,
dass alle 5 Min. eine kommt.
Das ist gut.
Endlich: Nach 48 Std. geht es los.
Hebamme, Ehemann und Doula
unterstützen die werdende Mutter.
* Stöhnen *
* Schreien *
Es ist noch nicht vorbei.
* Stöhnen *
(Hebamme) Der Muttermund
ist fast ganz geöffnet.
Du hast toll mitgearbeitet.
(Alessia) Na, siehst du.
(Hebamme) Das Köpfchen
ist ganz unten. - Super.
* Eva stöhnt. *
Toll, wir sind stolz auf dich.
(Hebamme) Ja,
du darfst stolz auf dich sein.
(Hebamme) Nicht mehr lange.
- (Alessia) Es kommt immer näher.
* Stöhnen *
Die Wehen verlangen Eva alles ab,
aber es geht voran.
* Schmerzensschrei *
* Eva stöhnt erschöpft. *
Gut, wieder entspannen, Maus.
(Hebamme)
Es öffnet sich bis auf 9 cm.
(Alessia) Toll.
(Flüsternd) Jetzt kannst du
gleich schieben. Dann ist es gut.
Du hast schon so viel geschafft
und machst das so gut.
Jetzt gibt es kein Zurück mehr.
- (Lachend) Nein.
(Schmerzerfüllt) Oh, verdammt!
* Schluchzen *
* Angestrengtes Stöhnen *
* Schmerzensschrei *
* Eva keucht. *
Man sieht schon was, Schatz.
Jetzt kommt das Köpfchen.
- Super, Eva.
Sehr gut.
* Schmerzensschrei *
Hier kommt jemand.
* Eva keucht. *
Er kommt gleich. Alles okay.
Jetzt hast du es fast geschafft.
- Er kommt gleich.
Er bewegt sich.
* Das Baby schreit. *
Dann ist es so weit:
David James Düby ist da.
* Eva weint. *
* David schreit. *
(Schluchzend) Hallo.
Hallo.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Hier zwischen dem Plastik
und meinem Finger.
Einfach ziehen?
- Ja, es ist etwas zäh.
* David schreit. *
Er atmet noch nicht so regelmässig.
Ich freue mich so sehr für dich.
* David schreit. *
(Lachend) Er will zu dir.
Der kleine David benötigt
Unterstützung bei der Atmung.
Wollen Sie mitkommen?
- Mhm.
(Alessia) Er steht
noch etwas neben sich.
* David schreit. *
(Hebamme, beruhigend)
So eine Hektik, was?
(Alessia) Aber er macht es gut.
Ich bin froh,
dass du auch dabei warst.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Ich bin froh, dass du hier bist
und Marc rübergehen konnte,
damit ich nicht ...
Schnell wird klar: David muss
auf die Neonatologie nach Winterthur.
Noch am selben Abend wird er verlegt.
Es sind bange Stunden für die Eltern.
Es ist nicht
so einfach zu verarbeiten -
insbesondere
mit unserer Vorgeschichte -,
wenn das Kind abtransportiert wird
und man es nicht mehr so oft sieht.
Der Plan
wäre ein Familienzimmer gewesen,
damit wir uns gemeinsam einleben,
den Draht zueinander finden
und den Dreh beim Familienleben
hätten rausbekommen können.
Nun ist alles ein bisschen anders.
Ich stehe psychisch teils
unter ziemlich grosser Belastung.
Es ist nicht ganz einfach -
insbesondere wenn ich allein bin.
Da wir einen Badge erhielten
und rund um die Uhr
Zutritt zur Neonatologie haben,
werde ich morgen
höchstwahrscheinlich
wieder nach Hause gehen.
Ich bin körperlich fit und habe
die Geburt sehr gut überstanden.
Es war eine sehr schöne Geburt,
ein absoluter Traum
von einer Geburt, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin froh,
wenn wir es hinter uns haben.
Die Pflegerin sagte heute,
es gehe ihm sehr gut.
Sie denkt, dass wir Ende Woche
nach Hause gehen können.
Ich bin froh, dass ich
bald wieder bei meinem Mann bin.
Er ...
... fehlt mir gerade sehr.
Aus der geplanten Woche
auf der Neonatologie
sind zehn lange Tage geworden.
Man nennt es Atemnotsyndrom.
Das ist ein Überbegriff
für Probleme rund um die Geburt,
die bei einer Lunge
auftreten können,
wenn sie noch nicht ganz bereit
fürs Atmen war.
Das Schöne an diesen Problemen
ist ...
... dass sie verschwinden
und nicht mehr auftreten.
Ob ein Kind nach der Geburt
eine Atemhilfe benötigt
und Mühe beim Atmen hat,
können Sie als Mama oder als Papa
nicht beeinflussen.
Das ist keine Frage von Schuld,
sondern es liegt an der Unreife
der Lunge zum Zeitpunkt der Geburt.
Wenn Sie nach Hause gehen,
ist diese Geschichte
jedoch abgeschlossen.
Alles, was danach kommt,
ist eine neue Geschichte.
Wir sind wahnsinnig glücklich,
dass er nach Hause darf.
Wir sind auch ein bisschen nervös
und hoffen, dass alles gut klappt,
aber wir freuen uns wirklich sehr.
(Pflegerin)
Nun ist der grosse Tag gekommen.
Ja, wir nehmen ihn mit nach Hause.
- Genau.
Hallo.
- Toll.
Ah, er schläft.
Möchtest du gleich üben?
Das finde ich gut.
Das sind die Gurte, was?
Einige Dinge
machen wir nun zum ersten Mal.
Die Beinchen
sollten ziemlich weit unten sein.
Mit einem gesunden Kind dürfen
die Eltern das Spital verlassen.
* Sanfte Klänge, Babylaute *
* David weint. *
* Weinen *
Das Fläschchen kommt gleich.
Mit dem Stillen
klappt es noch nicht so ganz.
Doch Eva beschäftigt
auch noch etwas anderes.
Nach der Geburt
hat sich herausgestellt,
dass ihre Gebärmutter
nicht operierbar ist.
Die seltene Form der Gebärmutter
kann immer wieder zu Aborten führen.
Für mich ist es
zurzeit eigentlich klar,
dass ich keine weiteren Kinder
mehr will,
da ich nicht noch mehr Verluste
erleben will.
Da keine Operation möglich ist,
weiss ich nicht,
ob es weitere Kinder geben wird.
Aber falls es nochmals zu einem
solchen Wunder kommen sollte,
empfangen wir es mit offenen Armen.
Ganz eingeschlafen ist er noch
nicht. Er hält mich noch fest.
Trotz dieser Neuigkeit
ist das Glück überwältigend.
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Liebevoll) Na?
Er ist einfach so süss.
Das ist ...
Und er ist ein totales Wunder.
Ich fühle mich
als Mama extrem wohl -
auch wenn es
mit wenig Schlaf verbunden ist.
Das Leben kann sehr fragil sein.
Und trotz Zugang
zu modernster Medizin
bleibt der Einfluss
auf Leben und Tod begrenzt.
Schaffen wir es wohl ohne Weinen?
- Hm ...
Mal sehen.